according to good are the main causes
of ticos eyes there are many cases to
have dry eyes the weather ok the
dryness that comes from the mild weather
its mineral and also medications that
you can take can cause dry
eyes women get dryness more
than men
a  older age can
cause dry eyes also
stress can cause
dry eyes so there are many things there
is not one that is bigger than the other
so we have to check it
out and find out what is the problem the ones
appear  symptoms in the eyes
there are many centers of dry eyes
you can feel that something is inside the
eye like sand something like that a pebble pebble
that is inside
the cream
may be a symptom of
dryness because most
people think that my eyes are
crying crying they cry but this could
be the dryness because it is the
brain saying you have to put more water
in the eye something else could  It could be that the
eyes feel bad how it is burning there are
things like that and also if it
was always blinking like that a lot it could be
the symptom that your eyes are dry
what are the treatments available
for dry eyes there are many
treatments
for stress you have to lower all three ok
why stress can cause you not to
sleep well
maybe you are taking more medicine
or caffeine like coffee and things like
that maybe you have to exercise they say
exercise better
to other treatments it is lubricants with
their diamonds because
there are two reflex modes have a part
which is water and a part that is oil and
these parts have to mix well in
the eye so you don't have dryness
so the treatment to put more water
is cleavage medications and the other part
is for the oil you can take more oil
in your body  but we also have a
margin that is called the dt flow to the
floor is an image that we can put on
the eyelids and this is heated on the
eyelids  It's up to about 106 109 degrees
and you can heat it up and clean the parrots at the
same time because the
soft ones are here in the
patios
if we can clean
it it works better and dry eyes can be better
and let's offer here
the bar there's fiction
this  nipple treatment